it's um it's definitely complex and it's
moving in the wrong direction right you
know I've been paying attention to uh
these companies that are buying up
affordable housing yeah if you like
black rock and Zillow yeah that's scary
it is scary because if they can move the
entire country into renting like that's
right nobody can own it that's what they
want to do right that's what I'm saying
they don't want anyone to own anything
if you get a giant majority of the
population that are just renters that
don't ever own property they never have
their own real real home yeah and then
you make sure that you control their
wage because you have massive
corporations whether it's Target or
Amazon or whatever and they limit the
amount of possible growth you have
within a company yeah and there was that
article you'll own nothing and be happy
in 2030. that is wild and this is you
know kind of you know when you look at a
lot of these think tanks and you know
groups of very powerful interests when
you look at the kind of world they want
they would like to get rid of things
like car ownership yes I've been seeing
that too they want to get rid of home
ownership they want people to all be on
the grid in a major way they want
surveillance you know Cradle to grave 24
hours a day seven days a week special
Credit Systems yeah and the only thing
that's left to do seems to be to to get
in with them
so that when they're doing this to
everyone you're with them yeah you're on
the right side of the place because
here's the problem people are Marching
into this willingly they're like
marching into it it's like my aunt or
the other Aunt like people as long as
their team wins they don't really care
what rights they lose and what things
end up looking like yeah they don't
there's a lot of people that don't they
and they're so tribal that if the
right-wing people want something they
want the opposite of that even if it
kills them and so I think that there's a
lot of exaggerated positions by people
that take up up these really like
Amplified right wing positions and it's
probably like Russian trolls right or
Chinese trolls or something like that
and they take up these positions which
force the people on the left to get even
more crazy with their Marxist ideas and
leftist ideas they turn it up they're
being played they turn it up and very
few people are autonomous very few
people have their own like well we're
also a silly country now so we have kids
in the suburbs calling themselves
maoists unironically ironic in these
leafy green suburbs and then we have the
alt-right and it's the same kids and
they want a return to the Holy Roman
Empire
and these are children running around
the suburbs that are online all day
venerating these genocidal dictators and
going this is a good idea yeah it's it's
a silly country and there's a lot of
problems and you know one of the first
indications that I saw that this was
coming was when Comics stopped doing
colleges interesting yeah because as
soon as you lose the younger people
because the comics are like dude they're
too [ __ ] politically correct it's too
annoying I don't want to do this they
don't have any World experience and
their their ideas are Preposterous and
you know they don't want any they
they're like the first to say no one
should own property they're the first to
say that absolutely you know that we
need a redistribution of wealth right
and we need which a little bit of is
good
income equality is a crazy statement of
course because should people make more
money yes yes they definitely should
sure if you look at a corporation that's
making [ __ ] Untold billions of
dollars and then you go down to the
bottom of the chain and people are in
dire poverty that are working for that
company and that company is benefiting
substantially it's crazy and that
person's the balance as well the battle
balance is way off and those people have
no leverage yes that's where unions come
into play that's why it's important but
that's why Jeff Bezos recently with
Amazon like he's taking the photos with
the girl yeah he's enjoying it it leads
to Amazon employees even though they
don't have food or Health Care can look
at him and go he's having fun you know
what I mean whereas a Warren Buffett
he's just in Omaha having sex with kids
quietly and worshiping Satan is that
what he's doing come on who lives in
Omaha there's a billion dollars it
drinks a lot of Coca-Cola he's got a
hundred billion dollars he lives in
Omaha why because he likes he lives in a
small house he says he likes Dairy Queen
let's cut it out but Bezos at least he's
on a raft with these [ __ ] in the
middle of the ocean at least that
inspires people's girlfriend I think
it's actually his girlfriend yeah she's
really pretty she's pretty in an
interesting way kind of does that mean
there's a shapeliness to her that's she
seems threatening like an animal she
looks like an agent ah kind of like
somebody that would play an agent in a
in a in a movie which is interesting
because she probably is an agent in real
life well she's a massage agent or
something dated a lot of other people
she's had children I think she's
American well God bless her and she's
making good choices I always tell women
if you can marry a billionaire right
Mario move marry a wealthy dude hang in
there for a couple years
to marry someone who will Who they make
money by destroying themselves while you
enjoy it which is many relationships
that I know a woman will enjoy the
fruits of a man's ever he will destroy
himself off and she will kind of enjoy
the money right but Bezos I believe is
retired well he stepped down as a CEO
but it's kind of like Putin right where
they never really step down interesting
but my my thing is like when you have a
country that's this silly yeah where
comedy specials are people
coming out making serious points you
have late night uh hosts crying you have
you know the girl who threatened her
mother on Dr Phil is a legitimate Star
right bad baby remember that woman oh
yeah she threatened to kill her mother
on TV she's a star now she has massive
Instagram followers massive massive
where does this go right pictures of
apes are selling for the cost of a
Lamborghini
our last president was the guy who
hosted The Apprentice and on his last
day of office a mob of lunatics ran into
the capitol to take selfies with [ __ ]
wigs on it looked like a sketch I would
do like it really is where we're in like
a [ __ ] weird movie do you remember
when you were a kid yeah you would hear
about the last days of the Roman Empire
yeah where they were just like eating
until they couldn't take any more than
stubbing a feather in their mouth up
you're [ __ ] everybody yes that's us
and it's
definitely like that it sounds good it
doesn't sound that bad but it is it is
funny as a community when you when you
step back and you go like this is
really really
crazy stuff it's crazy stuff and the
problem is I don't see a good ending
because if we fall in the other problem
is we have to compete with China and
China has this amazing ability to
control their population through
propaganda and intimidation and you know
total censorship which we're like moving
in that kind of general direction right
which is really scary because the the
one way we may be able to compete with
China is to become more like China
because otherwise like they're so
they're so integrated
they're um the government and their
business is inexorable they're connected
you cannot have a corporation where the
government's not involved right so the
government makes decisions with the
corporations that benefit the government
benefit the Chinese Communist Party
benefit the country in general